Some more heavy lifting. Let's talk about the
distributed data structures that GMS has in order
to do this virtual memory management across the
entire cluster. First thing that GMS has to
do, is to convert a virtual address, which is a local thing so far as a
single processor's concerned. And convert that virtual address
into a global identifier, or what we'll call
as a universal ID. And the way we derive the universal ID from the virtual
address is fairly straightforward, if you think
about it. We know which node this virtual
address emanated from, IP address. We know
which disk partition contains a copy of the
page that corresponds to the virtual address. That
we know. What are the i-node data structure
that corresponds to this page? And what is the offset? So if you put all of
these entities together, you get a universal ID
that uniquely identifies. A virtual address. This is
the offset within a page. So given a
virtual address, the first three parts uniquely identify
the page, and the fourth part identifies the
offset within that page for that virtual address.
And this we can derive it from the virtual memory system as well as the UBC.
There are three key data structures: PFD, GCD
and POD. These three data structures are the
workhorses that make this cluster wide memory management
possible. Let's talk about each one of these
things. PFD is like a PH table. Normally in a PH table what you do is
you give it a virtual address and the PH table says oh, I know what is the
physical frame that backs this particular virtual address.
That is the translation between a virtual page number
and a physical page frame that hosts that
virtual page is contained in a page table. Similar
to that is PFD, it's called the page
frame directory. It has a mapping between a UID,
because your virtual address has been converted to
a UID. Given a UID, it says, what
is a page frame that backs that particular
UID? That's this data structure. Because we're doing cluster-wide
memory management, the page itself can be in one of four different states. It
could be in the local part of that node. And if it is in a local part of a node.
Then, that page could be a private page or it could be a shared page. These are
two possibilities, there is living in the local
part of the physical memory of a node. If
it is in the global part, we know
by definition, global part is only hosting clean pages,
so the content of global cache is always.
Going to be private pages and so the state
of the page that happens to be the
global cache of a particular node is guaranteed
to be a private state. And the last
possibility is that it's not in the physical memory
of a node, but it is on the disk. So the page frame directory. Just like a page
table, says that either this page that you are looking for go from VA to UID,
that page is in physical memory and it is one of these
three states or its not in the physical memory, it's on the disk.